how did you get involved with liquid
death
um this company was brought to me i
think it was during the pandemic or
maybe before it's great waters at every
[ __ ] 7-eleven yeah they were just
like you know we want to do a deal with
you there was some people who were tied
in with some people
that i'm really close with and they were
like we would love to work with wiz and
blah blah blah and it was just kind of
like an organic thing they were getting
started
and i like the direction of how they
were doing it they were like we're
really extreme we don't give a [ __ ]
about the rules like the way we promote
is like really oh it's crazy hardcore
you know what i mean and like we're
going after it and they had a whole game
plan
and it was linked in with live nation as
well so every live nation concert
uh venue liquid death is sold in so
that's me all summer you know what i'm
saying or anybody who is uh you know
with the company you're gonna see this
company there so that's like how you see
monster energy drinks all over the place
this is [ __ ] water bro
so to me i'm like that's that's a big
big deal right there
everybody needs water no matter what